you
one of the very important aspects of
University College of London from our
perspective here at Yale is that in
Europe they have the great of advantage
of being able to have access to newer
technologies newer devices much sooner
than we do here in the United States so
the relationship is actually very
important for us here within the u.s. so
when you have a heart attack then the
doctor puts a catheter into your
coronary artery blows up a balloon is
called angioplasty and blocks the
blockage that's causing the heart attack
he keeps the artery open by putting a
metal scaffolding in it called a stent
the problem is that that stent irritates
the wall of the artery and in some
patients causes a second heart attack by
its very presence we're going to stop
that happening interventional cardiology
is really where we treat coronary
disease structural heart disease and
it's very device focused and again one
of the great interests of this
collaboration is to drive the device
side and device evaluation and I think
we have an incredible opportunity with
these two institutions we're really at
the forefront really of being able to do
this so we've got a fantastic idea that
we should put a metal stent into the
archer in the heart which is
biodegradable which just dissolves away
over a few months and then we should
make that stent magnetizable so that we
can take stem cells from the patient's
own bone marrow attach an on a particle
of iron to those stem cells inject them
into the blood and the iron on the stem
cell will be attracted to the magnetism
in the stent in the heart there the stem
cells will create a new lining to the
arterial wall
to make it a new artery again and then
the stent will dissolve that we can
build a completely new biological
archery without having any metal work in
it we're taking this from early concept
to prototype development to animal
testing to first in human and then
hopefully to Europe where we can get it
approved and on the market so we're the
stage of development and again I mean
the his biodegradable stent is going to
follow the full course of what we are
able to do between these two
institutions really take it from the
early concept all the way to market and
that's the idea so I think that's
basically leveraging our strengths again
on on both sides it is a wonderful
project that might bring a new hope for
people suffering from heart attack the
important thing in science is idea idea
that leads to experimentation if you
don't have novel ideas you just doing
experimentation without knowing where to
get the Yale UCL collaborative is
producing a higher quality of creative
ideas that will drive our future
experimentation to a higher level that
would have achieved alone